les automobilistes français en route
pour paris en dépit de l'interdiction
décrétée par la préfecture de police et
de la fermeté affichée par les autorités
à quelques deux mille six cents
véhicules selon la police faisait route
en début d'après-midi vers la capitale
lille nice bayonne perpignan regardez
ces images de nantes en voiture en
camion en moto ou en camping car tous
veulent rallier paris pour dénoncer les
restrictions sanitaires mais également
le pouvoir d'achat des français départ
depuis orléans notamment notre reporter
katia techniques étaient sur place
boissons plusieurs convois de plusieurs
centaines de voitures mais on ne donne
pas beaucoup de détails ici bien sûr
puisque pour qu'elle fonctionne il faut
que l'opération puisse coordonner donc
très peu de choses filtrent il ya juste
un comité d'accueil dirons-nous qui
prépare une enceinte ils ont des
drapeaux et des sympathisants des
participants au convoi de la liberté
donc qui attendent des voitures pour le
moment évidemment ces sont des convois
qui roulent très lentement bien entendu
car il ya énormément de participants
alors ce qu'on veut la liberté bien sûr
il est inspiré du mouvement canadien
mais ce n'est en aucun cas la réplique
primo il n'y a pas vraiment de camions
puisqu'en france et bien ceux qui
roulent en camion en sont en général pas
propriétaire et puis surtout ce n'est
pas un mouvement conservateur c'est un
beau pas un mouvement qu'ils sont liés à
trump là bas mais ici absolument pas il
n'y a pas de figure politique ici on
nous l'a bien rappelé les personnes qui
sont sur cette zone c'est un mouvement
apolitique pacifiques et les
revendications et bien elle rappelle
bien sûr celle des gilet jaune c'est à
dire des revendications pour davantage
de pouvoir d'achat contre la hausse des
prix la hausse des carburants évidemment
contre les mesures sanitaires les
restrictions de liberté ces personnes
ici sont usés elles veulent un retour à
une vie normale avec davantage de moyens
bien sûr est donc en attente de ses
convois ils ont ils on a vraiment un
désir de pouvoir s'approcher de paris
pour faire la différence pour montrer
qu'ils existent pour faire entendre leur
voix en tout cas se montrer grâce à ces
convois de l'autre côté on du côté de
l'exécutif et bien c'est attendu d'une
manière pas un petit peu hostile à on va
écouter le premier ministre en caisse
techci réagi à cette arrivée des convois
à près de paris je ne peux pas nos
quinquas laisser associés cesser ses
attaques virulentes contre la
vaccination est le mot liberté mot
liberté et non la liberté c'est pas
celle je les ai déjà dit dix fois de
contaminer les autres blogueurs arrêtés
quand ils arrivent sur le périphérique
qui seront tous avaient été atteints et
là aussi soyons des choses simples le
droit de manifester est d'avoir une
opinion est un droit
constitutionnellement garantis dans
notre république dans notre démocratie
le droit de bloquer les autres ou
d'empêcher d'aller venir de l'est pas
donc oui nous avons pris j'ai demandé au
belize intérieure au préfet de police de
prendre des mesures pour ne pas bloquer
comme c'était semble-t-il un station des
manifestants pour le tableau qu'ainsi à
paris ils seront arrêtés il serait
absolument bien sûr dix contrôles seront
faits s'ils bloquent la circulation ou
six ans table de bloquer la capitale il
faut être très ferme là dessus encore
une fois je le répète on peut être
contre en france en a le droit mais on
doit respecter l'autre alors je suis en
ce moment et que monsieur pâris un qui
vient appuyer ce convoi monsieur paris
son cache sexe vient de dire qu'il ne
souhaite pas un que ces convois puissent
restreindre le mouvement autour de la
capitale qui ne veut pas qu'on associe
le mot liberté à des questions de ne pas
sanitaire privation de liberté pour lui
ne signifie pas ne va pas et que le pass
annie terre qu'est ce que vous en pensez
bah la liberté on l'a pu parce qu'avec
le passé ni terre les vaccins tout ça
donc c'est pour ça il nous est allé
roddick à sion c'est pas le gilet jaune
c'est le peuple c'est l'ensemble du
peuple c'est les retraités la baisse de
la retraite c'est le pouvoir d'achat qui
est élevé qu'il faut augmenter les
salaires n'augmentent pas il ya les sens
j'ai fait que de porter aussi donc les
ponts c'est à la fin du mois ils
n'arrivent pas à joindre les bouts quoi
ils ont le frigidaire qui est évident
donc maintenant vous qu'on réagisse
voilà mais on n'a pas dit blocage jean
castex il dit ça mais c'est parce qu'on
a dit nous c'est pour se montrer ou à
l'information est montré réalité des
choses oui vous les voulez aussi insisté
sur le fait que c'est un mouvement
apolitique comme à l'époque les télés
gilet jaune mais vous aussi avec ses
convois vous avez des revendications
sociales finalement oui ces
revendications mais sans politique ouah
ça fait des années je veux pas que
politique voilà et je reste comme ça
c'est comme ça qu'on prend le montrer
aux français faut qu'on avance vous
imaginez que ce mot mouvement va être
très suivi de ce que vous savez déjà bah
je pense mais je peux pas vous dire
parce que voilà on verra ça sur la
surprise
merci beaucoup monsieur pâris donc nous
restons ici nous suivons la situation au
fil de l'eau nous vous dirons comment ça
évolue